so you think about putting the band back
together huh but I don't think that
group of workout man stop acting like
you don't miss it I mean the women the
cheers
the tips I do but how you gonna do that
with your leg my dancing days is over
but I got a ringer I am not a clown I'm
a magician you need to tell your face
when you moving out I am tired of
sneaking men in the last one I had there
was so loud when I let them come in my
back door I was scared he was gonna wake
you up
I got you something you needed Mom
thanks but it's a one-way ticket there's
only one way you're gonna do this Merlin
your way
Once Upon a Time near the finest male
dancing troop in town the chocolate
chips
it was a gold mine Mr face Mr Bobby Mr
Slim sexy Dr X and the one and only
Mr Big
why don't you go get ready you got a
tough crowd waiting for you
you want me to go out there alone and be
a stripper but I'm a magician ain't no
camp in Vegas
are you seeing what
I'm be back in business you haven't
talked to the chips in years how are you
gonna find them
you out of your goddamn mind excuse me
Lord
to be the stupidest idea I ever heard in
my life
we have fun back then
let's give it up for Dr Xander pipe
Santa's right Gus the mask and the flat
ass it's time for you to get on stage
and do it your way
[Music]
turn
without further Ado ladies
it's showtime brother
hey that's not what a thing guys
[Music]
yeah he over banging